Transcriber: Rasha Adil Ahmed AHMED
المدقّق: Bassant El-Ghazaly
دعوني أبدأ بسؤال من هنا فشل من قبل؟
أرفع يدك.
يوجد أشخاص رافعين كلتا اليدين .
هل من المفروض أن ننجح مباشرة ؟
بالضبط، النجاح خطوة مهمة جدًا لحقيقة الفشل
والفشل بالنسبة لي شيئين، فهو إما أنك تعرضت
لتجربة وفشلت فيها واستسلمت للفشل هذا،
يا إما أنت مررت بتجربة جعلتك تتعلم
منها للمستقبل أو تفيدك في النجاح،
أنت بالنسبة لي لم تفشل .
بالعكس، أنت نجحت لأنك اكتسبت خبرة مهمة جدا
تسهل لك نجاحك و جعله
نجاح قوي ومستدام.
في عرض البوربوينت،
ممكن أظهر موضوع الفشل والنجاح،
مثل خطوات السلم التي تمر بها  وهي مرحلة
وحالة فشل تتعلم منها جيداً بعد
ذلك تصل للنجاح الذي يجعلك
واثق من نفسك عندما تصله بنسبة مئة في المئة
لقد مررت بتجربة حيث قدمت عدة أماكن للتدريب
و في عدة شركات وتم رفضي لكن فجأة أحدهم
أتصل على هاتف المنزل يعرضون علي وظيفة
أخذت سماعة الهاتف ووجدت شخص
يتكلم بكل سلاسة يخبرني أنني قدمت على عمل
وإني مازلت بالأعدادية أخبرتهم إني بالجامعة
وأريد القيام بعمل تدريب فأخبروني
أن حسابي الألكتروني يُظهر إني مازلت في
المرحلة الحادية عشر ويجب علي تحديثه
لولا تنبيه هذا الشخص لي للقيام
بتحديث معلومات
حضرت بعد ذلك عدة مقابلات عمل،
وقبلت بعد ذلك في شركة فايننس سبورت
لمدة سنة ونصف أعطتني أفضل وأغنى الخبرات
التي أكتسبتها قبل أن اتخرج من الجامعة .
ذلك يُعلم كل شخص و يعلمني
أنا شخصيا حقيقة مهمة جدا أن كل شخص يجتهد
ويُطور نفسه ويتعلم من الفشل دائماً وينمي
قدراتهُ أكثر وأكثر،
سوف تأتيه الفرصة التي يستحقها
توصله لما يريده.
بعد فترة بدأت بالتفكير ،
حسناً، قد أصبح لدي خبرة جيدة
في الحياة العملية.
الآن أرغب بعمل تجديد.
أن أبدأ المشروع الذي أردت عندما بدأت في
الجامعة تقريبا، حدث معي موقف كنت
قدمت على شيء لكن للأسف لم يتحقق فتخليت عن
الفكرة لكن ظهرت لي فرصة التقرب لأثنين من
أصدقائي هما عبد المنعم و علي ،
وبدأنا على الفكرة و نتكلم مع
بعض تكلمنا لأيام ولساعات الى أن
ترسخت جيداً يجعلنا نحن نعرف نبدأ فكرة
الجامعة ساعدتنا جدا في هذا
الموضوع ونحن مستمرين فيه .
بعد ذلك أو قبل ذلك فكرت كثيراً لماذا كنت
أصاب باليأس وانزعج كثيراً عندما أفشل؟
أحياناً لم أكن أعرف ماذا علي أن أفعل؟
لكن الشيء الوحيد الذي استطعت أن أقوم به
هو عدم السماح للفشل بالسيطرة علي.
لأنك إن سمحت له بالسيطرة عليك فلقد
استسلمت له، لكن إذا فكرت ما هو الشيء
الذي يمكنني عمله بصوره خاصة
لتعطيني فرصة لكي أقوم بتحسين نفسي
بذلك سوف تصبح مقاتل يصعب هزيمتك،
شخص يمكنه الوصول لما يريد.
كل شخص مهم، لديه شغف، يمكنه
تنميته وإظهاره بمجهوداته
سوف يعرف أنه شخص يمكنه الوصول وتحقيق
النجاح، فذلك شيء جيد.
هناك شيء يجب أن تتذكروه, هو ألا تستسلم
و أن الفشل مرحلة تحتاجها لتعبر للنجاح.
شكرًا جزيلاً لقدومكم .